je vais vous parler aujourd'hui d'un
produit que j'aime beaucoup parce qu'il
est très modulaire parce qu'on peut
faire beaucoup de choses avec parce
qu'on peut l'emmener partout avec soi
est parce qu il vous rendra beaucoup de
services ce produit
ce n'est pas un smartphone se produit
c'est le picopix max je sais pas si vous
connaissez ce produit il est sorti il ya
quelques mois le picopix max il est
vachement cool il est vachement
intéressant c'est pas le vidéoprojecteur
vous allez installer dans votre home
cinéma pour regarder des l'ont filmé
pendant des heures c'est pas son adn
c'est un vidéo projecteur qui est
transportable qui va s'adapter à vous à
votre vie de tous les jours à votre
façon de vivre vous n'allez pas avoir
une pièce une installation fixé au mur
ou je ne sais où avec un vidéoprojecteur
qui ne bougera pas non là vous allez
avoir un vidéo projecteur qui bouche un
vidéoprojecteur vous allez pouvoir
emmener partout avec vous qui va pouvoir
vous suivre que ce soit dans un hôtel
pour une présentation professionnelle à
la fac dans des cours au lycée
pourquoi pas c'est votre prof est
d'accord mais également chez vous pour
regarder des films du contenu multimédia
pour aller voir votre grand mère et lui
faire défiler vos diaporamas avec vos
photos
bah oui grâce à lui vous allez pouvoir
faire revivre les bonnes vieilles c'est
en diaporama chez vos amis lorsque vous
rentrez de vacances afin qu'il ya
beaucoup de possibilités qui s'ouvrent à
vous moi je trouve super bien super
intéressant il n'est pas parfait il ne
fera pas tout mais ce qui fera il le
fera bien et vous allez voir produits
franchement il est assez redoutable
ladies and gentlemen voici le picopix
max un vidéo projecteur qui est posé sur
un trépied
mais surtout un vidéoprojecteur hyper
malin que permettra de faire beaucoup de
choses
laissez-moi vous montrer le matériel
alors vous le voyez déjà et un effet un
peu mieux roi on se voit mais bon c'est
quand même plutôt sympathique votre
vidéo projecteur et lille peut tirer des
attaques de même il peut tenir en gros
dans une seule main facilement pour
pouvoir le transporter en fait il est
posé sur un pied pourrait venir retirer
le pied très facilement où l'installer
si vous le souhaitez vous avez donc
votre petit videoprojecteur qui est là
et vous avez votre côté pratique avec le
pied c'est que ça se lit très facilement
vous avez une tête rotative pour venir
orienter votre vidéo projecteurs comme
vous le souhaitez donc ça c'est vraiment
très très très très pratique et très
malin comme ça il va s'adapter à tout
type d'intérieur tout type de table et
compagnie en plus facile à angers je
vous montrais dans quelques instants
parce que oui effectivement ici l'idée
c'est la mobilité pouvoir emmener
partout son vidéoprojecteur et puis le
produit en lui-même il est fait comme ça
vous le voyez dans vous avez votre
ampoule je vous en parle dans quelques
instants d aération tous les côtés et
surtout à l'arrière vous avez des
connectiques et c'est ça qui est
vachement intéressant qui va venir nous
plaire ici le bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre vous pouvez insérer une carte
microsd pour venir afficher vos photos
quelques vidéos vous avez fait très
facilement mettre du contenu à
l'intérieur vous pouvez brancher
également en hd mais ici ça peut être un
ordinateur ça peut être une console de
jeu très facilement mais également de
l'usb ici un petit peu plus standard
vous avez une sortie audio vous allez
pouvoir brancher des enceintes vous
allez pouvoir brancher un casque vous
avez une prise usb c'est pour la vidéo
donc pour récupérer tout le contenu qui
vient de votre macbook pro de votre ipad
pro ou de votre pc windows qui a une
prise effectivement en usb c'est vous
pouvez et si vous leur recharger en usb
sait et c'est là où c'est aussi
vachement intéressant et très malin ici
vous avez un pad et vous venez piloter
votre vidéo projecteurs grâce au pad
vous pouvez naviguer facilement dans les
menus il ya une télécommande même si
toutefois vous l'avez pas vous l'avez
oublié bien vous pouvez faire
directement ici une touche retour home
les menus baisser le son monte le son
parce que oui ici à l'intérieur vous
avez en plus des haut parleurs vous avez
deux haut parleurs de 4 watts
on aura une source audio qui sera pas
complètement dingue mais si vous mettez
un petit film une projection un petit
truc à regarder comme ça et bien vous
pouvez y ait de l'eau à l'intérieur ça
vous évite
de brancher un casque ou d'avoir des
enceintes donc ça c'est vraiment hyper
pratique je continue sans accessoire
parce que c'est vachement cool déjà vous
avez une petite sacoche pour venir le
ranger comme ça vous allez pouvoir
l'emmener facilement avec vos petites
sacoches philips la télécommande qui est
assez minimaliste mais qui fait très
très bien le taf vous l'allumez vous
l'éteignez vous pouvez venir naviguer
siècle petit bouton ok et en plus si
vous le souhaitez vous appuyer là et
vous utilisez votre télécommande comme
une souris sans fil pour venir naviguer
très facilement je suis sur youtube je
descends bagelet s'appuyer et je navigue
comme ça dans mon contenu facilement je
peux aller voir ce que je vous fais un
petit qui est très pratique ça c'est
vraiment sympa comme ça votre bouton
home bouton retour le menu montrent
elles sont belles elles sont ici c'est
pour lancer l'autofocus la mise au point
votre bloc de charges pour venir le
charger bien évidemment en usd c'est
grâce au câble usb usb ces messieurs
trouve vachement malin comme c'est un
vidéoprojecteur que vous venez emmené
vous pouvez emmener en déplacement avec
vous bien vous le voyez vous avez si une
prise européenne mais également au top
vous pouvez aller aux usa très
facilement mais également vous pouvez
même partir en angleterre pour venir
vous branchez dont pouvait faire le tour
du monde avec sans aucun problème sans
enlever d'adaptateurs de voyage ici
c'est du 60 100 watts mais il vous faut
bien ça pour venir le charger parce que
si vous avez quand même une grosse
batterie à l'intérieur de 16500
milliampères heures pour qu'il faut
quand même du temps pour le charger
trois heures de charge dont vous pourrez
regarder votre contenu soit avec la
batterie que vous avez intérieur soit
également en le branchant sur le secteur
quand je vous dis que c'est hyper malin
et très pratique en plus de cela vous le
connecter au réseau wifi de votre
intérieur vous pouvez également le
connecter en bluetooth à vos appareils
si vous le souhaitez notamment pour
mettre de la musique sur des enceintes
il est compatible apple airplay que vous
pouvez venir casser depuis votre mac
vous pouvez venir castet depuis votre
iphone depuis votre ipad
on a également ici mira casse ou à venir
castet de l'android très facilement vous
pouvez casser
depuis un pc windows depuis une tablette
sur la prise usb applaudir brancher une
clé usb pour récupérer du contenu vidéo
il photo également et enfin d'une
expérience qui est extrêmement riche que
ce soit pour regarder des séries des
films vous avez les fixateurs j'ai tout
tout vous montrer ici par contre
l'affichage c'est du full hd même si à
4k est compatible affichage 16 9ème ou
4/3 et vous afficher une image de 30
pouces jusqu'à 120 pouces et vous avez
3h30 d'autonomie mais vous avez
également 16 giga de stockage voilà un
peu partie logicielle comment ça marche
on est ici dans une androïde pv
le catalogue d'applications ceap torride
que vous avez ici sur votre gauche en
jeu montrait rapidement parce que c'est
vraiment très très pratique pas besoin
de s'inscrire ici vous allez avoir des
découvertes des nouvelles applications
notamment youtube pour android
disney plus smart youtube tv netflix
soyez pas mal d'appui aux avant tout
plus de 4000 applications prime vidéo
firefox pour venir naviguer sur internet
vlc pour vos contenus multimédias et
laisse quand même ici vient jouer à des
jeux vidéo j'ai plein de jeux dans mon
catalogue abdou ido cas c'est assez
sympa et ce qui est très cool c'est que
je peux dire en plus de sa brancher une
manette en bluetooth une vraie manette
en nous tous pour utiliser mon
projecteurs comme une petite console de
jeu garder lancera un peu de formule 1
je dérive
directement ici comme çà ou là là je ne
suis pas un champion comme ça je peux
venir je vois des jeux directement avec
emma petite télécommande et c'est assez
intuitif
c'est vraiment vraiment cool c'est pas
mal de transformer ce petit
videoprojecteur en une console de jeu
alors je suis pas un très très grand
joueur mais malgré tout j'arrive quand
même à jouer ça c'est plutôt sympa de
pouvoir retrouver tout mon contenu et
flix méfier ce que je regarde en ce
moment ce que je peux regarder vous avez
différents player spotify baby mais je
pense que globalement il est assez peu
d'intérêt parce qu'on va écouter de la
musique ici
et voyez pour me regarder les tests de
monsieur retrait facilement vous pouvez
le faire
le 2 pas trop mal si vous le poussez
trop font comme ça directement inclus
par leur smartphone à un petit pois
saturé mais vous voyez un truc est pas
mal vous le voyez tout en haut à droite
la garde est là juste là vous voyez ce
qui vous reste en batterie et lorsque
vous êtes sur l'accueil ils vous
marquent le nombre de minutes qui vous
reste pour garder votre contenu avant de
venir branchez vous venez naviguer ici
grâce à votre trek pâle et un côté très
pratique il n'est pas très lourd il fait
à peine 850 grammes vous pouvez donc le
mettre dans vos bagages dans un sac
s'est pas particulièrement le poids que
l'avenir vous déranger on n'a pas
d'information sur le processeur on sait
ici que c'est un processeur à quatre
coeurs cadencé à 1,5 ghz et je le dis je
le redis une fois de plus ce produit moi
je les aime bien je trouve vraiment
super pour venir vous déplacer pour chez
vous pour une pièce vous pouvez en plus
le mettre à la verticale vous pouvez
venir le mettre sur plafond vous coucher
dans votre livre vous projeter sur le
plafond enfin ya plein de solutions
c'est extrêmement pratique je vous le
dis une fois de plus la limite tout seul
comme ça c'est la partie audio mais
malgré tout ça reste quand même très
pratique comme vous allez pas forcément
être très loin pour brancher un casque
ou des enceintes et c'est un vidéo
projecteur qui coûte 899 euros
vous avez trouvé en promo bien
évidemment en cette période je vous ai
mis un lien bien sûr en bas dans la
description
moi j'aime beaucoup ce philips picopix
max très pratique il n'est pas adapté à
tout le monde il est adapté aux
personnes qui sont nomades qui veulent
l'emmener avec eux quand ils le
souhaitent faire ce qu'ils veulent le
connecter depuis un ordinateur le
brancher d'ailleurs on peut faire plein
plein de choses moi je trouve vraiment
super a vous de me dire vous maintenant
ce que vous en pensez
qu'est-ce que vous verriez comme usage
avec ce vidéoprojecteur est ce que vous
pourriez vous projeter avec un
vidéoprojecteur vous allez pouvoir
emmener très facilement pourquoi pas
projeter la main comme ça si vous
n'arrivez a pas bougé pendant très très
longtemps
moi je trouve très cool a dit pas ce que
vous en pensez en bas aux commentaires
trouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler tech parce que oui
parce que oui il ya plein de choses qui
arrivent et plein de choses qui se
passent de l'amour beaucoup des gros
bisous et à très vite
ciao garderie
à garder à tout prix
[Musique]
carney